hey this is presh talwalkar reminding
you to mind your decisions
in the ncaa march madness tournament a
bracket typically consists of 64
basketball teams playing single
elimination games until there's a single
champion
the question is what are the odds of
getting all of the picks perfectly by
pure luck it's an interesting
mathematical exercise that i want to go
over
so one way to approach this problem is
to first count the number of games
we can do this by counting the number of
games in each round
the first round involves 32 games
because each of the 64 teams is paired
up with another team
now each subsequent round will involve
half the number of games because half of
the teams are eliminated in each round
so the second round involves 16 teams
the third round involves eight teams and
so on and we keep having the number of
games until we get to just one game
where we have a champion
we can get the total number of games by
adding up these numbers and we get 63
games
now i want to mention this is the long
way to do this
the shortcut is you can notice that all
64 teams lose exactly once except the
champion that's another way that you can
see there are 63 games
and you can generalize this logic that
in a tournament of two to the end teams
with no buys there must be two to the n
minus one games played in total it's a
nice little combinatorial identity that
we learn from march madness
so now let's calculate the odds if each
pick has a 50 chance or probability of
one half of being correct by pure luck
well picking one game will have a chance
of one half
so we need to pick 63 games which will
be one-half to the power of 63
this equals 1 over about 9.2 quintillion
which is an astronomically large number
because it's so hard to pick a perfect
bracket that's part of the appeal of
march madness
good luck with your picks
thanks for watching these math videos
available for free on youtube build
confidence for students and inspire
mathematical discovery for viewers
around the world they have over 100
million views and the channel has over 1
million subscribers please subscribe for
free to get the newest videos and email
me a puzzle or math topic
mindyourdecisions.com if you so choose
you can check out my merchandise on
teespring you can check my books listed
in the video description and you can
support me on patreon thanks for
watching and thanks for your support